people are afraid of confrontation in
terms of like overcoming i believe that
you can sell without ever having
confrontation and you can do that with
what i like to call childlike curiosity
and so if someone says my husband's not
going to approve that i'm like i
wouldn't huh that's so interesting tell
me more about that rather than like all
right let's like your husband's an
[ __ ] like that's not going to work
because in arguments no one wins right
and so like why why would he think that
because because i would think that he
wants what's best for you right yeah he
wants what's best does he know you're
struggling with this right now well i
mean yeah he knows i'm struggling with
it okay so he wants us because he knows
you're struggling with it so why do you
think he would be opposed to solving
something that that you're currently
struggling with just so i understand
would he be happier if you continue to
struggle well no it's like well great
then would you be opposed to moving
forward today and that way and hey if
you go home to your husband and you make
a joke and it lights a scenario and then
you close it right and so it's i think
childlike curiosity is the immediate
that you have to train because people
get defensive okay tell me more about
that and like now you're interested and
then they don't feel like you're
combating them they feel like you
genuinely are interested and want to
help them which is what you should be
doing